That was once the original
trigger that my little sister
was 16 years old I
ordered it from the USA for $60 including customs
and thank you Influenz I thought to myself that's about it,
okay,
we're still standing with ours
products on the shelf that is still
growing but we knew to make the big
leap now the chick has to
be for us so that would really have been for
a whole new brunch more we
don't have the giant shelves have the
stone otherwise roll so we say  always
Amazon with our business angel
and retail was our um because that was of
course just cash flow um they had
me after Douglas
DM Rossmann came relatively quickly DM Rossmann two extremely
successful ladies finally
do a podcast again and the
gummy bears filled with
dietary supplements then cost
lonely  glass 25 € pretty unbelievable
but it worked really well the
whole story of BS with benefits of S  ony
and Lena let's go,
welcome to the OMR podcast we were
just talking about our
regular guest Sven Schmidt taking his hat off to these two
ladies we have
two women as guests who recently sold their company
in a very short time
2018 only founded it  is
a dietary supplement brand that
comes in the form of gummy bears above all we are talking about BS with
benefits are guests a rose tournament
and Marlena are in hi thanks for the
invitation you are actually wernerin
i already have a career before in the
filmcity area but i have at lorea
I worked in Paris at Unilever in Hamburg for a long time and that's when I ended up in classic
advertising in Munich in the agency
where I also met Lena and
what was Serviceplan or what no
that was a small medium-sized
agency yesterday we have it
grown from four people to 40 people
in the last 10 years  we both work together with
the two founders
two brothers and yes we noticed
we can work very well together
are very
complementary i.e. done TV advertising or digital
projects
brand development projects also for
in the consumer goods industry there was a
bit of it that at some point we felt like
it too  I set up and started to do something myself in the area
and that
was actually the reason I
then went from Hamburg to Munich, it was actually
quite
difficult, but yes, everything worked out quite well
and then, so to speak, waiting there
together with the agency  and you
kind of thought now you have to have a
real blood company and what
could that be and then you had the
idea with this gummy bear with
its nose in it yes if you like how it was
just like the passion project to be honest
at the beginning we saw  we
just have resources, uh,
we got a bit frustrated at some point  rt
from our own customers in the
consumer goods sector where everything is always
thought much too tightly is
not thought of digitally at all um then everything
always has a tendency towards the middle
everything is
given to market research at some point and then the
cool ideas are gone again and have said
um, maybe we should just develop our
own products and, above all, a
brand that is digital right from the start
, that is somehow as
cool and as we
imagine it to be and then we
looked at what could we do
or where are ours  own problems that
we would like to solve and that's how we got
into the areas of food supplements
and what exactly was selling there
now in detail so gummy bears
what's in there
that are vitamins vitamins and
minerals in the form of gummy bears
and they just solve certain
problems, for example that  what we
also brought here for the hair
is our bestseller
like that  was also our very first
variant that we developed,
but meanwhile we have a
portfolio of almost 20 different SKUs
and there have been a lot more
when I can’t sleep,
e.g. something with melatonin or
variants with collagen for the face
or energy bears  we also
brought it with us and there are always different ones that are
really coordinated
we develop it together with
a doctor in a team with
nutritionists with
pharmacists so that the complex of the
vitamin complex is really
coordinated with a specific problem that we
then want to solve and  this idea they
are in the shape of gummy bears are enough
these are, shall we say, relatively much
innovative or not
yes, well, we did
n't invent that either, so we don't want to wear the shoe
at all because there were
other brands in the USA that
did it  There were
always gummy bears in pharmacies in Germany too  n for children
with vitamins in it so the idea
itself is not new for us it
just fitted really well with the product because
we
wanted to make dietary supplements especially for women we saw
at the time that the market was
actually quite under-
innovated  So is the truth still so
totally somehow rational white male
and everything always so no idea on performance or
protein and for women
there was still almost nothing and
that was actually our perspective
that we thought we would make
food supplements for
women  then it's just a bit more
emotional and um from the whole
packaging from the whole impression
and um we just wanted to
do it in a very positive way, so we don't want to give the
so-called people or our
customers the feeling that you
're missing something now you still need something  you
somehow have to optimize yourself even more
and somehow even better  what do
I know but really
wanted this positive
simple product that helps in everyday life
so our main customer is
also the classic multitasking mom in
everyday stress and that's exactly what the
core of jam jars
really is
like and he kindly gave me three
piece and I asked
how much the glasses cost and
then I was pretty Bach what does a glass cost
€24.90 24
unusual but is
absolutely possible you shouldn’t see it as a
jelly bean it’s not
comparable to one with a Haribo
or a  Katjes pack but you
only take one or two pieces a
day depending on the variety, which means you
really have to compare it with one another from
supplements and also a very
high-quality food and
we are very well in this price
range because we not only wanted to
just make gummy bears but also
a product that works in
high doses is what the clean  is
where there are no fillers
titanium dioxide magnesium stearate there
is a lot of stuff that is often mixed into the classic
white tablet or capsule
and we really wanted to create
a small, high-quality
product that would somehow be part of your company
just from the raw materials and its
price  or
do you buy ne we make
manufacturers because meanwhile we mainly work with
a producer Germany
exactly then searched researched exactly researched for a
relatively long time we actually want to do it
right from the start
but to be honest it
wasn’t that easy in Germany
because of course we  we started with a
relatively small batch,
so we didn't have a big
business plan and somehow we had the idea that we're going to
do a huge
start-up here somehow, but it was more
like a bit of an
idea, oh come on, let's do it
own product what we cool  find but
we lean that just explained and
the second trigger was actually a
little bit let's do something at
Amazon and then we went
relatively north as well this
whole Amazon optimization but
we knew or what does it mean we just
thought it  there won't be 20,000
pieces that will sell immediately,
but we wanted to start with a very
small batch at the
time of 3000 and not produce the whole thing in
Germany
warned in the direction of China
uhm took care of a producer
there these production
sizes were okay then these batch sizes and then yes
then we started with the
product is a producer with whom we
are still in contact today is not
that long but 2018 me  I think we're talking
clearly, but things really happened in
quick succession with us, uh, after the after d  en the
first beginnings at Amazon so that I
got into these batch sizes really quickly
so that the production
could move to Germany
our first so not the first
flavor but the first,
so to speak, supplementary
solution the hair product so the amazing manufacturer
with that is also the bestseller to this day
is a skin hair
nail complex with biotin folic acid zinc
and skin hair nails that's just the
beauty need par excellence for women
that's why but on Amazon many people are looking for
it and especially in 2018
I think we just really have another
one like that  I think others
had already started at Amazon before that, for
example 16, but for us 2018 was
really a great time because that’s
how it actually started with a
yes this whole
market food supplement
was a bit on the move
something new happened to us  then with
our completely new speech for
women  en new carrier product and
many have already searched for it on Amazon
and funnily enough we
were actually listed on Amazon relatively quickly
for the keyboard gummy bear before Haribo
because we had really
good conversion rates and good
click rates, so you could already
see that  were a product that was really being
searched for but also very generic
keywords hair hair loss hair loss
or something like that optimization at Amazon good
purchase conversion then it will be
exactly so we actually
invested a lot of time in
the packaging that was exactly the
topic that we thought  So
much is developed for the shelf, I
've always seen that from my FMCG perspective
and we wanted to
develop digitally and packaging digitally has to
look different, so it was
important to us that the contrasts
first of all really popped out on
this one, uh, very much  pink for example
in the case the first was ta  actually
a lot pinker that has keywords
directly on it no so that
the conversion rate also so that you
just really understand immediately what
does this product stand for what is the biotin
hair
exactly that
works super well on small mobile surfaces from the
packaging that is  also with um
in a search list on the desktop at
Amazon if somehow everything is
white more or less in the
area where our product just totally
pops out so we have already
tested a lot beforehand and put a lot of
love into this packaging
and  were then really very quickly rewarded with
really good conversion rates and
click rates on Amazon,
so I think we somehow had a 25% conversion
rate. At that time we were then very
quickly bestsellers in the category
and then really relatively quickly, so
I think the first the first can
we sold in August and in
November we were gone  in the
bestseller category and made really
relevant sales and were
totally amazed at how well this product
went I mean, this gummy bear idea did
you just tell us
?  In principle, yes, but
food supplements are
also regulated on the market and you can
not enter
the German market or other
European countries with just any US product, so
the biggest player in the USA in particular had
problems there again and again because the
declaration  on the label not for the
European
market with Kim Kardashian and Kylie
Jenner,
they were very well known, well, that
was actually the original
trigger that my little sister,
who was 16 at the time, ordered it
from the USA for 60 dollars including customs
and thanks influenza because
I thought okay about the The  ma's
almost there blatantly okay and now done
even without capital you can read about it yes
we cleaned the company to the end
and that was exactly how it went
on Amazon started really small umm
you make sales immediately we also have
the first batch directly in  fba-
warehouse so it doesn't have to
be big in any way, starting with 10
20,000 € pre-financing one then that's
actually exactly I think each of
us put in 5000 € at the beginning
more or less the GmbH founding and
from that we have the first one
Paid the batch and then we tried it out
relatively easily in Amazon’s marketing
, but we were really
lucky that the product was in
the right place at Amazon at the right time
and that
developed really really well very quickly and  then
retail came to me, so then Tina
Müller
had this startup at Douglas, I think that was also in November
Challenge announced Beauty Futures
is called today exactly
yes we were the first winners of
this ah okay
2018 that's exactly what we won and
then in January we were listed directly in
Alsdorf at Douglas and that was
the moment when we went to the German
producer
said so now we have our quantities here,
our 20,000 pieces per
production site, roughly and uh, exactly
the gummy bears are vegan, so
we actually only use at least 95 percent gelatine
in the variants where we
use collagen as an animal
ingredient, otherwise it
’s important to us that the  Gummy bears are
vegan we work with pectin or
starch but yes it's now like
dietary supplements I think in
general that's not rocket science
but I come from Unilever
that's not rocket science
at
all  there
it goes
right and he has Amazon then  came
Douglas and how did he get even bigger
or how do
we make our business angel and retail
was ours like you um because that was of
course simply cash flow that we then
had after Douglas came relatively quickly
DM Rossmann
reported they were actually all
in with us  reported the joke was
that Douglas had so douglas gave
us total support, especially
in the first year and they then had a
trade fair as their main sponsor, I think that
was the Beauty Independent back
then in 2019 and Douglas had a
huge stand as our main sponsor
then we were invited to come along
and present our brand and at this trade fair
Bipa DM somehow
got to us. Everyone chatted up to us because they saw
our big
brand development, just in
this Douglas environment, and then one thing actually came to the next
, so
he always makes the DM first  via a
test listing we
entered the race with three products and
one product was chosen  n just from the start
it sold so well that
DM actually listed it immediately
this is just here the beauty without
sugar has been
on the shelf at dm for three years now I've seen
there is also a time when you have
at least somehow  had a
lot of fun and erm exactly then
somehow I don't know three four
people we were in 220,
we then grew to almost 20 in 21
because we just saw we launched
our own
online shop in February March 2020 on  Shop basis
and then it ran so well, of
course we also had Corona tailwind,
you have to say, but we wanted to take that with us again
in 21
and then really invested in a relatively senior
team, so we have a
few head of  recruited
and then went straight into the expansion
, to Italy, to
France, to Switzerland, and
erm that was really easy at first  It
only cost me money for this one year,
yes, it was millions in the
end, yes, it wasn't a
problem afterwards, I also asked myself
how it was actually managed
when I saw the number in the annual financial statements
, but yes, we made
it, we still have it ourselves  I
made my capital increase last year
but we really believed in it, we took out
a bit more
from the family and loans
we discovered revenue based financing for
ourselves then in the second
half of the year that helped us enormously in
future sales you already
borrowed from somewhere else then so factoring also means
or  yes, well, it's actually like that, you
get loans at a certain
interest rate and you start paying back immediately
based on your shops,
so it's really connected
with shopify
out a bit,
so there's just different ways to
recognize that, okay, I think so, and
then we'll give  you
actually based the loan so that the sh  opify
shop is docked Amazon is
docked to such a dashboard and then
it goes like this Google
rating say we give you such an ex
to you with the interest rate then you
can negotiate a bit and then
really immediately start paying back
differently if you have high
sales  do you pay back more
are a fixed percentage let's say 20% of the
daily turnover if you make less
turnover you also pay correspondingly less
so
to finance exactly but that's just
in contrast to classic banks with
which we have been extremely sluggish because
the company was somehow two three
years  old we two female founders
so with the classic bank we
didn't get very far in
contrast to this, these revenue best
financing providers were immediately willing
to give us money because they saw the
numbers and the current
ones and the banks then gave you  it was
correct conversations then was sent home
or yes off  solut well
we took out a KFW loan at the end
last year that was
the last piece of the puzzle before
financing but absolutely we had
to break our teeth at the banks that
you can't put it any other
way somehow yes so to this day
I don't think we have any  Dispo is somehow
we don't need it
either, of course, but yeah, well, it was actually
much easier to talk with a click or
ancap like that, they're just
used to doing revenue-based financing
to finance startups, who
immediately saw, okay, the marketing
efficiency  is really good operationally the
margin is super so it's just a matter
of time until we somehow
implement a little bit then are simply at the level
that you can think about the fixed costs again
so the the the lever the
operational lever that
was still there  um, it was relatively clear that
at some point it would just be enough if we
stopped in certain sales sizes before
zi  so to speak, that we can then
also think about the fixed costs very well
and that was before
2021 or something like that last year we had a
turnover of 6 1/2 million euros
that was almost 200% growth from
20 to 21 so it was just a  Yes, the
extreme growth where it was clear that it would be
difficult to make it profitable
, but then it jumped into the eight-digit
range
and was already profitable, so Q4
last year was already profitable
and we continued like that and
then this year it will be at 10
or  12 or something like 15 so again
okay okay and what is the biggest
stream now is still Amazon or is it now
we are now doing 80%
we just moved
away from retail last year and added to our
own customer data and also abroad
so we do it  that here in
Germany Austria Switzerland Italy
and France and a total of
80%.  okay you knew that
because he wanted to save on the trade march
or no no no not really
tried reasons so you have to
say such a retail business if you
somehow move a few pallets
R that is much more profitable than
building it up direct to consumer somehow and
really  having to acquire every customer first
, that costs money
and
ultimately, of course,
it just takes a while until you have a
relevant size where it is
really
fun and that’s why it wasn’t
necessarily driven by profit, but
actually  more so that we are
more sustainable or simply believe that
a business is of course
much more promising in the long term if you
have your own customer data and
can easily control the expansion
yourself and the product range too,
so we wanted to expand the breadth you
can do retail with the Chef Space
is extremely limited you can j  a don't
stand with ten variants so
some brands can do that for us or
become difficult we wanted to
offer a lot more products we wanted
to grow to 20 SKUs now and really
serve a wide variety of beauty and health needs of women we also want to be a
long-distance relationship so  we know
women simply have a wide variety of
health
needs and nutritional needs in their lives in their different phases of life, be it a phase when they want to have children, a phase of
pregnancy, a phase of
menopause, and we wanted to
answer that offer with our products
, some of which are very niche,
you can only sell them in B2C, so there
is a buyer  for that and that's why it
was always our goal at some point
to sell the judiciary ourselves with
this wide range of products and
how do I get traffic to the
shop now, I mean now the
trade understands ne that would have accepted and then put it
in their shops R  ossmann and co
now you have to take care of the traffic yourself
but how do you do that Instagram
performance marketing in general so that
's Facebook Instagram that's Google they
are also influencers
says influencers probably
start with 30,000 influencers so of course there's
another one this year  Classically
actually like the moms who have
themselves in life are now not the
youngest so more in the direction of
somehow 30 or just like
over 40 who just have something to
tell and
yes, you actually
just
believe it when they say it
somehow have their children standing here in
life somehow have their their
multitasking and everyday work
exactly for a long time they are also
really fans the product just
remembered they also appealed to us
at the time for him advent calendar initials
effect connection we recognize so
if I somehow  take and
there now  I'm working on my hair loss
now somehow you have
to believe in it it's a
bit okay I'm doing something good or what
is the effect of this
supplement for the vitamins that
are in there are there officially approved
statements of effectiveness at EU level the
so-called health clames that have
really been proven by double-blind
studies, that's why you can
meet them and that's biotin helps to
maintain normal hair exactly the
same you can say for prevention of zinc,
for example,
and then of course it doesn't work for everyone
because many  People don't have any deficiencies
at all if you don't have any deficiencies at all
because you
eat an incredibly balanced diet then you won't have a
great effect under the menu but
and many people have it then
you will also see an effect and
now you can say the rest  is
somehow placebo or wishful thinking we
actually always look at our
trustpalet reviews the  are at 4.75
stars because that
works very well for most people,
nonetheless you always have
people who say it didn't help at all
and if I came up with another use
case, for example, I
'm a bit afraid of flying you're
also  these sedatives
exactly that was recommended to me more often
that you should take it before
long-haul flights
I haven't done
it for a long time but next time I wanted
to somehow get three
gummy bears in and then I crash because of
it or maybe not
three straight away but always  pay attention to what is written on
the package if his
body has just fallen asleep on the plane but you do
n't have this day-night rhythm
it doesn't get really dark
either that's why it isn't produced then that's why
there are approved for melatonin that
helped small
ones that's um deadlack reduce  can and that is
can shorten the time it takes to fall asleep
deme  Accordingly, it's best to take a little
bear to start with, then you'll have a
milligram of melatonin, see how
you drive with it, but yes, that helps a
lot of people extremely, even
coaters,
whether they are deliberately advertised according to
the motto here will fly somehow more pleasantly
or something  flying is now
a bit specific in the group
we are already coming from the sleep direction
so falling asleep faster sleeping
through the night yes telling the
influenza to the older children or
tiktok we are just starting again
a bit for us it is
extremely important because of the bootstrapping
all marketing channels cables
work corresponding Roas also
have what inflation exactly and that
was not the case with tiktok for a long time
, so last year it only started
a bit with advertising actually
that’s why we have there when we see we’re
burning more money then  we
usually stop relatively quickly
when we n  ot got optimized in a very short time
now we're starting
again but yes we have
n't done that so
yes but we also have a startup
competition so we are the queen
competitions that really bring something
Adventures Patchday won this
year there was a media budget of 3
Millions of euros to be won and that's
why we can't even do it on TV now,
yes, if you started that
a bit in September,
but really only a week or two of
testing, so we ca
n't say much about it because we're confronted with a
stock art  there are
unbelievable problems along the way, especially in
the procurement of raw materials and we
actually have a stock type of our
bestseller, so that
would have done nothing at the point of the
TV set shooting out,
so we actually have a
complete delivery of product
failed our producer  said
sorry you won't get 50,000 pieces the day after
tomorrow  was that a bit stupid from the
timer when we start again in January
how big should I measure the
product
according to supplements generally have
a very good per tomato that you can
say
we have product costs of around 20
%.  80% tend to be on the
product Marketing and the whole
logistics payment are, of course,
other variable costs and marketing,
ultimately
the packaging, you also have to
say that the classic
food supplements usually come
with this plastic packaging with the
plastic lid are not
particularly nice to look at  er
, we're already investing purely in the
dark glass, the vitamins also
I guess that's really
a nice thing to look at and
marketing costs were then somehow
down on the product, which then
marketing costs, so to speak, about 30%
more expensive in the end the marketing
we produce  Of course, we
also have to create a lot of trust for the product
, so it's important that
you see it from different channels, too,
we also invest a lot in
content, including in the doctor in
nutritionist, that's
ultimately marketing for us, that
you simply exp  ertise around the
topic also supplements and pharmacy and
nutrition create around the product
played out and right now
trustpires is still playing a role and
Google Reviews so every kind of review
tool is totally important you
just have to read that it worked for others
so that you  you also
bring trust in it because
we are not a farmer brand that has
been around for 100 years or
that is in every pharmacy, but that
is a young startup and um you have to
trust that as a
consumer and really everything is a
review platform  so I
mean to hope that then just
being cool writing people
probably didn't know enough how
proactively design these videos
exactly so at trustpilot
we actually actively write to the customers after they
have bought and ask them to leave a
review inside on the one hand
their shopping experience on the other hand
also from their product experience
externally, i.e. at Amazon
, we are probably not relevant
either, we had thought about it for a
while and
experimented a bit with it that
instead of sending out the invitation for trustpalet for
Google,
we don’t do that anymore because we can see that trustpalet  is
actually a large, relevant
platform, independent, independent, exactly,
and we’re actually doing very well there
, and Google there, of course, every now and
then someone rates it and also
good, I think Google has a
4.7 or something like that, but that’s where
we are  now not actively following and
so the typical customer bought a glass
or how many so what are there were
head always ordered our
shopping cart in Germany is
around 50 € tendency to increase
no more like three to four actually because
we will do that with discounts if
you  buy more than one can because of
course it's just tabler for us, in the
end we're subsidized  We also lower the
shipping costs, for example, because we
really want this product to
be simple, the whole shopping experience
should be simple, so the customer pays and
has no shipping costs
we actually
decided from day one not to
do it that
way and if you calculate that when you calculate the
costs, we simply see
that it is most profitable for
us if the shopping basket is over €50
and then we will intensify that
too  I like it when you buy more
and uh have
to buy again exactly, but a
customer will be customers together and just keep
shopping again and again, thank God we have that
very high and that is uh and the
linchpin of the business model and
then he does it via e-mail  or how
do you think this
CRM in general is mainly e-mail
currently another word for e-mail
or yes a  lso WhatsApp has just
arrived very well, we have
n't tried it yet, but Charles is
definitely on the plan for next year
, too
Keeping the loop with content,
magazine content, yes, and of
course simply the entire lifetime of the
customers, we just try to use it as best we can
to simply
keep in touch
and encourage the customer to buy again, it
is important that the blood is vegan in the end
is whether he just corrected me there
um so is vegan required
or is your wish to do it or
yes that's important or more but
being vegan it's that it's not
gelatine gelatine is mostly between
somehow everyone knows it's actually
um and  since we already have
collagen variants that are not vegan
, we always get how  the feedback why
is it like that i don't want it or that
also has the highest
return rate for example just do
n't know is vegan but actually
imagine there's
or two percent or something but
nevertheless of the products
those with gelatine are the ones that are returned the most
but  We also actively offer that to
our customers, for example,
so we really say you can
send it back at any time if you
like it or if you
somehow have the feeling I have
no idea it's no use no we
really offer it to every customer
on the website and  we do that very
aggressively, also in the customer
emails afterwards, that I can
send it back and get a full
refund, even if the can has been
opened or is even empty,
then you give it to someone else,
so yes, we don't need it back at all,
but you  get your money
back if you are not satisfied
that is also a trust factor
and yet the people
who are now using it I do
n't think the rate is 2% or so
really extreme and there are other
measures to somehow increase the trust
so this whole platform
has now heard he works together with the
doctors and  Content is a
topic that is still there Stiftung
Warentest probably doesn't exist for that
there isn't either you can't
actively make inquiries clearly press PR we've
also made it relatively strong in recent
years because the
classic women's magazines are also
an authority in this area  are always
reporting a lot about beauty and health, yes, and
simply satisfied customers, so when
they talk about it and
recommend it to others, that's actually always
the best marketing in the end, and uh
, we've grown really well so far,
so luckily we always have a
lot  a lot of new customers that we
address and, um, with whom
we also managed them  we have
more than doubled from year to year, so
we can see that there is just
something in it, no, when they
talk about it, they also recommend it to each other
and, um, it's
about 40% 40 45%, um, exactly
Leaving retail, I mean,
I recently
spoke to the founder of kosnova,
who has become very big in retail.
If you are successful in retail
or if a retailer
delivers successfully, let’s say you can
build up a really great business and
it seemed to be everything for you
already set up there and then you
've already decided no, we
'd rather go the chick way that seems
pretty crass to me that
you really can't get there so so to speak
now I'm going away from the path that
is currently leading to success  and how
do we go about it from scratch in the
hope that's what I just said so that
I can create even more varieties or
even more offers okay
but
the desire for success has become
even more stronger than after one
because that is still growing but
we knew in order to make the big leap now it had
to be the chick for us
so that would really have been more for a whole
new industry  we do
n't have the huge shelves of Kosova
at dm or Rossmann, so
growing one product out of that so much that
wouldn't have been possible, I don't think, no,
and I don't think we ever wanted to make ourselves
dependent, so I think
we founded it too  somehow out of
the need
to be able to act as independently as possible and then
you have the dealer or
Amazon again and then until he somehow again
in his form of dependency and
always has to look okay how much he
buys now ne can I with him
grow further how can I somehow
plan further and for us that
was actually always the wish
from the beginning so we actually have  h
rather took the detour via
retail for cash flow reasons and
for reasons of bootsdrapping, but from the
beginning the desire was really
possible to be able to design it yourself
and that is of course
if you have your own job and can use it for
your own customers
like  you would like to do that and you can also
develop your own portfolio the way
you would like, regardless
of that, ok I can now on Amazon
I somehow get the reach
for but
why did you have this company I sell
my things for everything after a great
story and  everything was
set up there too now after the move
to seeed for long-term success
growth why do you give it away then
so we are still relevantly
involved so it's not
like we gave it up completely
but instead  for us it's
actually more like that, we've now taken a
strong partner on board,
what's his name
Calculate HW and behind it there is also a
pe-bite, the partners who now
together with Tabea and with us simply
want to clean up the European market a bit, I think, and err just want to
create a big a big basic shape
in  in the area of ​​consumer hair
supplements and I think we can
still do an awful lot together
and get out of it and that
was the reason why we thought
okay that that fits so on the one hand how
did it come about that hour so did they talk
to you did you talk to them
or  yes, well, we have actually already made
a structured process and
since last year
Boutique exactly the company Karlsruhe has
approached us there in the last year
exactly because we are very grateful so
greetings to Karlsruhe at the
point they have an insane chick
track record with them  the most diverse
brands that means we
actually hit it off straight away a  We felt safe,
we still thought for a few months
whether we
really wanted to do it now, but in
view of the current growth
we saw that we wanted support for the future
in the area of
operations in the area of ​​finance, that
's not really what we are anymore
basically we are already
at home in the burning and in marketing and
in product development and
we actually want to focus on that we
these are our strengths and we already
thought that I think it is the right
time now that the whole thing is reduced to 15
minutes and and  upwards then
taking partners on board and
then we started this process and in
the end we were very happy that
we found a strategist and
not a purely um
financial investor who now
wants to continue on this path with us okay and
that means then  did you
meet different potential buyers and
they liked me the most  convinced
our most convinced yes because they
can really offer us a lot
uhm that was a great team too so the
deal team but also overall the company
is really cool has a good spirit
wants to keep growing they
also had this  Event that they were
just bought by Partners that
will be the last owner that is
itself private equity that also means
for us a great whether I
would of course have money to bring the firewall to Unity on the one hand
but also in the
future again from further growth
to be able to benefit and how are
such films rated, so what is
the usual multiples on
sales or earnings or how
does it work
on the yes, it depends
from Hawa now I assume
that yours is not really
from  5 are valued at one billion
okay exactly
between two and five in the
consumer goods sector
two then that would be
30 million for you  and five then that would
have even been
75 somewhere in there
okay between 30 and 75 that's
not such a huge range of course it
's live changing or something in
between but generally getting there
is absolutely great that we
actually still own 100% of the company
held in the end and now didn't have to
give anything to investors GmbH doesn't belong to us anymore, which has
just been sold completely to anhabiya
, but we in turn have
a relevant share of the
sales price in anhabiya,
so in the entire group, so
then always put it on now  50 €
and then you took the 50 in your
hand to hold
something and what how much money would be a few percent
, we don't have that many shares,
so 200% of it,
so still mine for a thing that
started in 2018  it's
already very crass so it's so fast
you're now millions heavy yes it went
incredibly fast so me  I think I
never thought of it myself,
so we didn't plan this company on the
drawing board, we never did the
blatant business, I think we wrote
the first business plan after a year and a half
, somehow she
asked for it, that's why it's
all the nicer, of course, it's so great
it actually worked  always very
strongly, somehow, out of the
gut and somehow
opportunistically genuine in the western sense, so
we always tried to use the
opportunities that were offered to us in the
best possible way, such as
a Tina Müller who then gave us the
douglas listing  So of course
we said we'd do it, although we had
actually
initially thought digitally, via
Amazon and maybe our own shop,
and then DM Rossmann came
along and then our first ones, so we
never
planned everything from A to Z in a totally rational way  at the beginning
but we've always been
a bit ahead of ourselves  at our own pace
,
yes, we can't say
that sounds so passive, but we've
always looked, okay, what
opportunities are there and how can we
use them and listen to them all first,
so the decision
at the end is not an investor on board  to
take it we still
listened to everything spoke to everyone we
certainly spoke to 20 like them
and to 30 business angels or you're
not always every conversation gives
you valuable input and then
you can always say no,
I don't do it
okay and in the end honest question so
you have to buy that was not the money what
was really this fit
or the decisive factor for the
final decision
so yes that was the
highest rating in the end but for
example not the highest payment in advance
Now someone else offered
it, but we just totally saw the
chance because we want to now too
both didn't get out that was actually very
clear that we would stay on board and
remain managing directors
and then I really want to do it
with a partner who is
very strong himself in terms of content,
who can help incredibly, who can
open up new sales channels for us who is
now also managed by the
founders no that by
no oh so yes okay but okay okay much
better um they have
bought six companies in the last six years one of them
from the whole group that’s exactly what I
’m really excited about  the fact that one of the
founders also believed so strongly that you lead
between the whole group, that also
shows us a bit of the
way where we can go in the
future and your team is
currently 25 people but including
werkies and internships okay
great  Beat yes super super
secret not to inflate unnecessarily
as far as that is concerned but to really try
to add it to Solin as possible  Egen
so always quite happy with but that can
now grow a bit again
and that was
actually because we had asked 21
earlier so we had in
21 we were somehow almost 20
people or something like that no and in 21  was
n't enough with personnel costs of
what I'm in six figures, then you'll be up
relatively quickly, then calculated over the year
with a loss of one million
more or less, but in 22
it'll be full because we can
more or less do very well with the same team
scale
logically you paid a small
salary I think
security paid we are
no longer in our mid-20s but nope never
beyond that so profits we have always
invested completely and now after the
excellent
business angels themselves or what the plan
yes
so
ecosystem give back find important
also because we are two women and there
are not that many female
investors we have experienced ourselves
w  ow it can be to sit on the other side
of the table and we have
experience ourselves, men don't take an idea or
a product
seriously either, and of
course we want to change that, which
is why it's extremely important now that
it's closed  do you now support
80% of your customers or 1900 women or something like that, so
what percentage is 100 or 90 or
so we, we address
primarily women, we don’t have a
product for men at all
and with the flight so if both are now
something  me right now so that's
why men also buy, but we
mainly address women who the
brand itself is already very feminine
okay
that means
you're now being given back a bit now look
at some kind of investments and kind of
startup ideas that toci can
you suit you quite well now you have
gained a bit of experience and
otherwise buy
the moment exactly
crass and then  we said to your parents
somehow there is no
such thing as that and you all said it could be something
special like a vacation or something spontaneous
but yeah well yeah I think we
really just have to take
a look at it because it's
real  somehow also
work in a real way, of course, interpret
now, read, no longer necessary, it's always nice to
do it now, but if
these numbers
are more or less correct, then you can calculate that
it would be fine, yes,
maybe, but I think we
both work  I
've always been passionate about it and somehow it's going on
straight away no you well
I always said hey
when this Excel process is over then we'll
both slowly go up for two weeks yes it
doesn't matter
but of course it's going on in
quick succession now it's coming  the
integration process um and your
counterpart for him it's okay or the
buyer for him he's going jet  zt only started
and accordingly you actually
continue directly there is
no such break that you always
anticipated
beforehand no and as I said we
would like to continue we are also well
involved so it is not
so that the complete purchase price
somehow ended up with us and
finished but exactly partly
French yes my father is French
that's why it's also close to the
French
no that actually had
nothing to do with it so Lena doesn't
speak naturally or the company speaks is
somehow half English he speaks um
completely  so native speaker English
actually
a bit so connected yes that of course
definitely but even if it's
just a good guy so lena
also connected directly with him and my
French is honestly a
bit rusty
but hopefully she'll come back
more often now  I can clear better than my brother
but we've also seen them
now  Strategists in Germany
it was just a bit slower so
we already had it
on the lonelist here would have been very
happy but a typical strategy would have been in
march for example special dragees which
that’s basically the mother of all
dietary supplements for women we also
have after your  Podcast here at
Kos Nova, of course, then also
said that they even make a
competing product at dm with a somewhat
younger one, but they also went in in
that area, so no, I'll say
something smaller, but of course also
somehow in
Unilever or Hohe Haus but that  Yes, there
are also many medium-sized pharmaceutical
and consumer goods companies, but
everything is a bit slower. They
really couldn’t keep up with the pace of such a process,
okay, or the process was only
half a year or so fast, but I
think we were still geeks
that you played back
yes so yes it came to us  a long time ago
but we were completely flushed back
that is a very fast processor I
think it can also take much
longer the perspective for the
back investment is now so that
at some point you really will bring it to the stock market
or that you can somehow
still do it now  resold in the next PE
or to the next
strategist, so I think there are
still a few large consumer goods or
pharmaceutical companies in the world for whom
it could make sense then, because at some point
the market in Europe will be available for purchase
for a total purchase price of one
billion  plus now clear
so the air
Congratulations at first I am very happy
so I am also proud that you came here after
work and I think in
general it was exactly at the festival
and so that now such stories are created
here with us that you that  so
mega so very very impressive so in
2018 we looked directly at the Amazon
report I think
all the reasons d  hey are here everyone has something
exciting to tell what should I make
every mistake myself you can also
listen to Christoph Gerber a little bit
okay
we always have the
challenge
of finding women who are currently
doing spectacular things like you
have someone there  that you wish for
oh yes we found the podcast strong, for example
yes okay yes I would
definitely recommend Dr Arne Latz our
medical consultant but
with hello inside she also makes a super
exciting startup glucose tracking in
Austria so so digital
um very tight  networked that's a
digital dermatologist app so I think
there are really cool women in this whole map-tech area
okay then let's take
a look thank you for
coming around and congratulations again so
very very friendly I'm happy for you
thank you all right
ciao  bye